you know it's so great this morning you
came into the room and said hi to all
the reporters you showed up early and
you make it so amazing to love it look
we just love you and we love your
character and the fact that here we are
in another season how excited are you to
be playing Bowl again yes well it is
revelatory I would say I'm very grateful
and humbled by how incredible the show
is I mean I I do believe that it's the
best written show on television and that
includes all of the you know all the
maniacs making Netflix all that I think
Glenn Gordon Caron does an extraordinary
job of weaving some of the social
commentary which is needed at a time
like now and also writing incredibly
indelible strong characters it's true
lucky you're lucky yeah and while your
character wasn't because he had a heart
attack and a lassie that's part of it
you know when you have experiences like
that it changes you so will we see a
different side of all coming into this
season yes I think that what's
fascinating is that Glen our writer is
not afraid of some of the more profound
questions and one of the things that
happens in bull season 3 is we have
these incredibly complicated emotional
episodes that serve to remind bull every
week that there's something missing even
when he's fixed himself up and fits into
that smart snazzy suit there's there's
still a chamber that's empty could it be
his heart will he find that I'm I'm a
betting guy in a sense the well you when
you become an actor you're that's
automatically gambling okay I don't
actually buy lotto tickets or gamble in
any other way right I think you're just
being an actor was a gamble right I
believe in love for bull but so well
I believe it will I know my magic 8-ball
says love is in the future but I don't
think it's necessarily the best thing
that can happen to someone who doesn't
have a strong foundation I almost feel
sorry for the woman that he gets
involved with because I think he could
present really well yeah and then it's
she might feel there's some sort of
emotional shakedown happening maybe some
love yeah I mean we haven't we haven't I
believe there is there are things coming
last season was really season two just
built to this crescendo he had a dream
about his ex-wife who was getting
remarried in real life and he had a
dream about that and they had an embrace
and then you know he woke up and he
thought what the hell is that about but
really she said to him Jason you're no
good alone and I think that in in as
much as the love of a good human being
for another human being is the best
thing you can do he spends all of his
energy helping everybody else and he's
gonna help this guy and that lady and
this dog and that kid and he's gonna
make sure that everybody else is okay
mm-hmm and there's one dude that's not
okay now this is based on dr. Phil as
when he was a trial consultant what can
you tell and does he consult and write
is the heart attack based on his life or
is that just written into the story so
one of the four fundamental
misconceptions about the show coming out
of the logline when the show got picked
up even to script was that it was a some
sort of biography you know there is no
aspect of biography what is very true
and phil mcgraw helps with a lot is the
trial science and the analysis of how to
best move forward in a in a jury trial
so how do you prep your witnesses how do
you select or deselect a jury
and that process is fascinating and it
is a component of the show but it's not
it's not a we're not following the light
of phil mcgraw I mean that would be I'd
be maybe the wrong guy to do that
because I don't think I'm that smart now
in the in the show what you kind of like
talking about that you kind of learn how
to read people hmm
you have a sense of people's energy do
you feel you've kind of gotten that
after playing this role or how are you
good at reading people how's that mmm
you know anytime you think you're good
at something you're probably not very
good at anything unless you know
somebody gives you a medal or a gold
record or a medallion of some you know
it's like I think if you get a trophy
for something you've been maybe you're
okay with you know but Pia Zadora got a
Golden Globe I don't know how it works
but I will tell you this we we know that
dr. bull is somebody who has a great
deal of insight a natural empathy but he
also has a great deal of training and
expertise in education and and as a
psychologist I am just an actor so I am
fascinated by watching how people behave
but sort of like a car salesman I'm the
worst guy buying a car right because I'm
the first guy to get fooled because I I
set myself up for it and I I think bull
is very different in that way bull knows
when somebody's trying to fool him bulls
biggest blind spot is it just himself
huh that was inspiring wasn't it yeah
all these stories in all this cases that
you guys covered in the last two two
seasons going into season three was
there one story that fascinated you oh
gosh yeah I mean I I found the season
finale of season 2 to be remarkable in
that bull is arrested for shaking a soda
machine that's not giving him what he
wanted out of the but he's drunk and
he's arrested for that kind of
a view and while he's basically drying
out in a cell he meets a guy who's mute
who's accused of this fire that
incinerated people and he decides to
help that guy for no reason at all
except it allows him not to deal with
his own problem bull I hope you feel
better I'm a little under the weather
right now he has kids we get it hmm two
little ones bringing home germs yeah I
mean bull should never be sick because
he lives in a tiny little world where he
doesn't even shake hands with people my
son today this morning yeah at 6:45 this
morning was eating muffin okay and he's
eating the muffin and he goes oh - and
the muffin just went like I had and my
wife just was like just it's okay and
I'm like no it's okay I'm just gonna
pretend that this is like a muffin face
wash you know like I'm a little muffin
mask with held together by mucus thank
you my son and as I often say to my
children I love you so much was it a
good muffin Ellie's a good mom corn corn
and carrot right